el partido comunista chino se plantea en
este congreso seguir combatiendo la
pandemia con medidas científicas más
precisas dicen está funcionando esa
política de covid 0 y Qué impacto está
teniendo en la economía de este país
sin duda está teniendo una desventaja
bastante grande frente a lo que se
buscaba en el nivel económico para este
año
estamos viendo que se tenía proyectado
un 5,5% de crecimiento y solamente va a
crecer alrededor del 2,8% según el fondo
monetario internacional sobre todo para
ciudades tan relevantes para la economía
como mínimo estamos viendo que se están
desacelerando bastante fuerte Por ende
ese es uno de los reclamos que se hace
en este congreso en el vigésimo en
frente a todo a todo lo que se está
planteando y frente al liderazgo decir
es el tema bastante fuerte y no han
funcionado como tal las medidas
Señor hubo una larga ovación cuando
shellín defendió esa soberanía de China
sobre Taiwán Qué papel juega este
conflicto de Taiwán en la imagen que da
chillimping ante los suyos
quiere buscar una parte de lo que
llamaríamos nosotros cortinas de humo
frente
en el desaceleración de la economía
recordemos que la pasada Estados Unidos
estableció nuevas sanciones frente a lo
que llama la seguridad nacional y esto
resulta bastante relevante frente a los
demás países también de Asia
esto que nos quiere dar a entender
también que a sangre y fuego dado en el
discurso de Hace unas horas de Pink
buscaría esa reunificación y que le da
un ultimátum la líder de Taiwán es la
señora ha dicho que busca unos canales
diplomáticos de mejoramiento de las
relaciones pero que la soberanía de
Taiwán no está en riesgo para nada
otro asunto clave del Congreso fue una
una política para motivar la natalidad
en el país una promesa para motivar esta
natalidad que tan importante es este
asunto para el gigante asiático
sin duda sin duda es fundamental porque
actualmente un tercio de tercio de China
está por encima de los 65 años ellos
quieren ser los líderes para el 2035 en
cuanto a tener una economía ya
totalmente moderna y ser la primera
potencia para el 2050 Entonces estamos
viendo un déficit así alrededor de 11
millones por año sin embargo las medidas
medidas de ya quitar un hijo por familia
desde el año 2016 no han dado los
resultados esperados porque la nueva
generación es de China quieren
desarrollar una carrera más fuerte a
nivel laboral